we want to uh have a big congratulations
they're in order for
the country power couple tim mcgraw and
faith hill i love them so much they just
celebrated their milestone 25th wedding
anniversary
ah yes and tim took to instagram with
the sweet video sharing his proposal
story and added in the caption 25 years
later and it's still the best day of my
life thanks for going on this journey
with me love you faith cute
how i propose to faith we had dated for
a while i actually asked her to marry me
quite a few times like she kept saying
no she said i'm not going to get
involved with another country singer
it's just not going to work out we were
somewhere playing this big outdoor
festival and they had these trailer
houses set up i'm getting ready to go on
stage
and i had this sort of case that had
this big mirror in it she's standing
there and we're talking and i said look
let's get married and she says you're
asking me to marry you at a country
music festival in a trailer house and i
said well it's pretty apropos if you
think about it she goes are you serious
i said well yeah i'm serious and then
they called me and i had to go to stage
i went to stage and did the show and
then i came off the stage and went back
into my dressing room and faith wasn't
there but i looked at the mirror in
lipstick it said yes
i'm gonna be your wife
and we still have that mirror and it was
uh
best day of my life that's for sure